[MUSIC PLAYING]
VALENTIN DELEPLACE:
I am Valentin.
I am a Developer Advocate
for Google Cloud Platform.
And today we'll talk
about performance.
And we'll talk about performance
of programs written in Go
running in a public cloud.
I have a lot of slides.
And I probably won't have enough
time to answer live questions.
But please come to me just
after the presentation,
and I'll be happy to discuss.
First, I'll share my insights
about what we want to optimize
and why.
Then we'll see
how we can observe
the performance of
a cloud architecture
and discover which
components best
explains the actual latencies
experienced by our users.
And finally, we'll
have a look at how
we can observe and improve
our components written in Go.
What is performance tuning?
Usually it's about working
on something that is slow
and making it faster,
pretty simple.
Why are we doing
this extra effort?
Some possible benefits
of improving performance
is to increase the [INAUDIBLE]
and to decrease the cost.
But today I am focusing on
the most important goal,
which is to offer a
better user experience.
Human seconds are more
precious than machine seconds.
Users have very high
expectations of speed,
and if they experience
a sluggish service,
they will get frustrated,
and they will leave.
The architecture of a new
software system designed
for a certain level
of performance
is always the result of
experience and intuition.
They reflect what
kind of latency
we should expect in theory.
However, measurements
are more relevant as soon
as a system exists, even
before its initial release,
and measurements often
contradict intuition.
I am an experienced
developer, and I
have intuitions where
most of the time
they are dispelled by
the actual numbers.
So on one hand I get frustrated
that my super-smart intuition
turned out to be dead wrong.
And on the other hand,
I am happy and grateful
that my measurements finally
provided me with insights
closer to the reality.
There is an interesting
correlation between code
quality and performance.
When you successfully
refactor some code
to make it faster, you often--
to make it clearer
and more decoupled,
you often end up
making it faster
as it's less cluttered with
irrelevant instructions that
were previously executed
in vain and also
because some possible
optimization now become more
obvious and easy to implement.
On the other hand,
if you push further
in your quest for
performance, you
will have to give up
simplicity and resort to hacks.
You will indeed shave
some milliseconds--
this is the green
line going down here--
but code quality will suffer--
this is the blue line
also going down now--
in so far as the
code will become
more difficult to read
and to reason about, more
brittle, and less flexible.
So it's a tradeoff.
How far are you willing to go?
Now a word about
automated tests.
Designing strong automated
tests is necessary
in order to make
optimization refactoring
without introducing regression
bugs at the same time.
Do you know the difference
between service time
and response time?
Anyone?
Not that many people.
That's great.
This 100 milliseconds
here is the time
it took for the service to
process an incoming request.
This is the service time.
But it might very well be
that the latency experienced
by the user was actually
700 milliseconds.
The user may have
a slow connection
or the request could be queued
by some data-center front
end invisible to
the server instance
until all the other queued
requests have been served.
This total latency
is the response time,
and it is always bigger
than the service time
as it also includes the network
round trip and the queuing
time.
In the point of view of your
web server, you may be thinking,
wow, each of my
resources are served
in 50 milliseconds or less.
This is really efficient.
That's 120 milliseconds
for my total page
having three resources.
Everything is fine.
And in the monitoring system,
all the individual resource
requests from all users
may be displayed together
in a complex interface.
And when you click
on a single request,
indeed everything looks fine.
Well, not so fast.
What the user really
experiences is certainly not
a meaningful page load
in 120 milliseconds.
Because of the current
design of the page,
the resources are fed by
three sequential requests,
and the total response
time is two seconds.
There is room for
improvement, and the best fix
is probably some
client-server front-end work.
And note the speed improvement
of the existing back end
endpoints written in Go.
For example, inlining
the most critical assets
could result in a dramatically
better response time.
So why am I saying all
this, and what does it
have to do with Go programs?
The point is that Go software
is usually server components.
The server components
are where we
have the most
accessible information
about performance--
the several logs,
the server traces, et cetera.
But it's too easy
to fool oneself
into thinking that when
the server is fast,
then magically the
whole system is fast
and the users are having a
pleasant, seamless, responsive
experience.
That is simply not true.
This is how looking
only at server latencies
of an internal
application at Google
I didn't even notice that
an important page was
taking 30 seconds to render.
The users were staring at
the blank screen, completely
unresponsive while the
JavaScript was performing
UI repaint over and
over for some reason,
and that was completely
invisible to the server
monitoring.
The first step to achieve
some meaningful and valuable
performance is a
sane architecture
that takes into account
the client-device workload,
the browser cache,
the network latency,
and the number of round trips
between server side and client
side.
Ideally we should
use a warm system
with user monitoring to
have the browser collect
valuable metrics so we don't
have to rely only on the server
metrics.
In the recent years, quite
a lot of the workload
and of the latency has
shifted from the server side
to the client side, and we have
to take this fact into account.
More generally, focusing on
the users is a good idea.
I can't overemphasize
this axiom, users first.
Now let's have a look at
the observability tooling
available in Google
Cloud Platform.
The Cloud web console
includes Stackdriver logging
which consolidates
the request logs
and the applicative logs of
your compute components--
so Compute Engine,
Kubernetes Engine,
the serverless components--
in near real time.
You can filter the view
by component, by keyword,
and by date.
So each request, each
line of the request,
you can see the full URL,
the size of the payload,
the timestamp, and the latency.
The latency is, of
course, the service time.
It's super useful, but
remember that it's only
a fraction of the response time.
Some of the App Engine
standard requests
have been automatically
instrumented.
If we click on the blue
link in the latency column,
we will see the waterfall
view of all the API
calls that happened during the
processing of this request.
I love waterfall [INAUDIBLE].
They provide with so much
insight in a single view
that I am even OK when they
are telling me you are wrong.
This is what really happened.
The Stackdriver trace
view integrated directly
into the GCP web
console shows me
for a given request
what API calls were
made, in which order,
how long they took,
and if they were
sequential or concurrent.
The top-right button shows
the applicative logs right
inside the waterfall diagram.
This is actually a great
feature of observability.
The spans tell me what happened,
and the logs tell me why.
In this specific example,
the total latency
of 62 milliseconds
consists almost entirely
in one datastore entity read
and then two datastore queries.
We have a few read and
write accesses to memcache,
but those are super fast.
Now I know that the
bottleneck is the datastore,
and there's no point
in trying to speed up
my memcache operations.
You can also notice that the
last two datastore queries
run concurrently, which is a
good idea when it's possible.
I strongly encourage everyone
to set up the automatic export
of all the logs to BigQuery.
Such an export is
also called a sync.
With BigQuery, you don't
have the default retention
period of 30 days
only, and you can
use SQL to query
fine-grained performance
insights over a large
or short period of time.
Can we please switch
to the demo computer?
So I will show you
live in my browser.
This is the back end of
a website written in Go
running on App Engine standard.
In the latency column,
the static assets--
1 millisecond, 1 millisecond--
have extremely low latencies.
They're actually served
by an internal CDN.
And here if I click on
the blue link of a request
to view the choice details,
I will see the API waterfall.
So this one just consists in
two sequential datastore query.
OK, fine, nothing fancy.
If I want to find
something that took longer,
I will filter, show and
trace with higher latency.
Oh, this one was
not really fast.
What was it about?
OK, memcache,
memcache, datastore,
something that can be either
some processing or just
some serverless weirdness.
I already have a sync to
BigQuery properly configured.
Here it is.
So I can ask questions in
BigQuery like in April for all
the requests that were
not made by a bot,
because I don't care
about search-engine bots,
and that were not
static assets--
so they don't start
with this prefix--
what was the request that was
the most frequently accessed
URLs, and what are their average
latency and their highest
latency?
Let's run this SQL
query in BigQuery.
We should have an answer.
OK, so the home page slash has
been the most accessed page.
The average latency was
only 5 milliseconds.
No, that's not better.
Only 5 milliseconds,
that's quick.
And the max latency was
about 400 milliseconds.
So secondly most
frequently accessed page
was the RSS endpoint, which
is not really user facing.
It's usually fast,
but sometimes it
can take up to 2
seconds, 1.7 seconds.
Maybe I should have a look to
see if I can speed that up.
There are some cases
where we'd like
to insert our own spans
in the trace waterfall--
for example, if we have
a CPU-heavy computation
or to show the duration
between two related events.
OpenCensus lets you do this
with its Stackdriver exporter,
and the Google
Cloud documentation
shows how to do this
for App Engine standard,
for App Engine flex,
for Compute Engine,
and for Kubernetes Engine.
OpenCensus and its competitor
OpenTracing are open source.
They have recently
joined forces.
The APIs will
converge, and this is
great news for the
cloud-computing-observability
community.
Conceptually, the best
view to understand
the latency of a component
is a waterfall view.
In this simple example,
100% of the server
latency of a request--
service time, no response time--
consists in six sequential
calls to external services.
The service works
well, but everyone
agrees that it is a bit
slow, a bit sluggish.
Here, I can see four
opportunities for improvements.
First, I now have a
better idea of the latency
of each of my dependencies.
If my database is
expected to respond in
under 100 milliseconds
but my measurements show
that each query actually
take 200 milliseconds,
then I know that
something should
be fixed in the
external database,
maybe create an index.
If I'm lucky, I just sped
up the database accesses
without changing anything
in the server code,
only by doing ops
on the database.
The total latency has
just been reduced a bit.
It's no longer 900 milliseconds.
I often witness repeated
access to the same service
with different
parameters and payload.
It is a law of the universe
that if the service
accepts batch calls--
that is if it accepts many
commands in a single API call--
then the batched
call will be faster
than the sum of the
individual calls.
Here we are calling
service B three times
sequentially with different
parameters one, two, three,
but we can do better.
By transferring the same amount
of inbound and outbound data
and asking for the same amount
of work to the service B
but in a single API
call, we suddenly
improved the total latency.
This may sound counterintuitive,
but it makes perfect sense
because some heavy costs
like the network round
trips, the network latency
component, authentication,
et cetera are now paid only
once instead of three times.
We sometimes achieve
this optimization
by wiping the commands
in a transaction.
However, batching
and transactions
are different concepts.
Transactions are
about atomicity,
and batching is about
achieving economies of scale.
This is what batching
can look like when
using a Go client library.
The code change is
not very complex.
We just need to know that it
happens to make things faster.
Most of the time it is also true
that making a few expensive API
calls concurrently is faster
than doing then sequentially.
Please note that
I am not talking
about CPU-bound local
computation here.
I am talking about
dispatching concurrent work
to the external world,
by which I mean outside
of my current server component.
In my case, the
calls to service B
are logically
completely independent
from the database calls and
from the email operation.
So I can decide to run service
B concurrently and save
some milliseconds.
This way all the
operations depend
on each other's
completion, so I can't
run them all concurrently.
As the batch call to
service B starts immediately
and is already finished when
the email has been sent,
it's effectively become free.
The total duration is the
same with or without the call
to service B.
For this simple
example of paralyzing
two independent
blocks of computation,
I suggest to use a WaitGroup.
I don't recommend
channels for this
because a channel's details are
subtle and tricky to get right.
WaitGroups are straightforward.
There are only three
methods to know--
Add to increment,
Done to decrement,
and Wait to let the main
goroutine move on when
all the task have completed.
Now please ask yourself if
the email-sending operation
is more synchronous or
asynchronous by nature.
In my opinion, if
sending an email
temporarily fails
for some reason,
then the user can't do
much with that information,
and it is the server's job
to retry in a few minutes.
I suggest that we add the email
operation to a task queue using
Google Cloud Tasks and then turn
immediately, once again saving
precious human milliseconds.
The task will be
executed asynchronously
after the HTTP
request has returned,
and it will deal with
with the retry logic
in case of an error.
Deferring some work
with Cloud Tasks
has nothing to do with
the Go keyword differ.
It's totally different.
It's also more code than just
launching a new goroutine.
Creating an asynchronous
task typically
involves serializing
some parameters
into the payload
of an HTTP request
that will be processed by
another handler of your app.
Now let's pause
and see the result.
A total of 200 milliseconds
instead of 900 is a huge win.
You can see that
this was achieved
without using any
low-level assembly code,
without upgrading the
underlying hardware,
and without even caring if we
have one or many CPU cores.
In general, it is most
useful to run the performance
tests on the same
machine configuration
as used in production.
Keep in mind that public clouds
offer virtual machines, which
are convenient
but don't give you
full control over the
underlying hardware.
Even if you achieve very
good average latencies,
you may experience
higher variances
than with dedicated hardware.
This may perturb the
tests, and in some cases,
this may perturb
the user experience.
My application written in
Go creates a mosaic in which
each tile is a colored cat.
Because of copyright
concerns, my input image
will be "Mona Lisa," and the
little cat is drawn by myself.
I need to specify two
parameters, the resolution
of a tile in pixels--
can we please
switch to the demo?
So the two parameters
are the resolution
of the tile in pixels
and the number of tiles
that will make the width
of the resulting mosaic.
So here I deployed this web
app to App Engine standard,
and I will request a low
horizontal resolution of 20
cats only, and I
will upload a picture
of my girlfriend, Mona Lisa.
Let's generate it.
Spoiler alert, it should
work, and it should be fast.
Yay, there she is.
We can't see everything
on the screen,
but it looks a bit like this.
It's really nice, but I
don't recognize anymore
the face of Mona Lisa.
So I will try
again, but this time
requesting a horizontal
resolution of 80 cats.
I can't remember if this is
slow or fast with the Wi-Fi.
Server error.
The server encountered
an error and could not
complete your request.
I knew it.
Let's have a look at the logs.
That's part of the demo.
Trust me.
So what does it say?
That's an error, and it
says exceeded soft memory
limit of 120 megabytes because
the F1 class of App Engine
instances don't have
very much memory.
So to produce a big
image, that's a problem.
So I deployed the same,
just changing the parameter
of the instance class.
That's the vertical scalability.
I will choose the biggest
instance available in App
Engine standard.
Let's do the same
in another window.
Where is it?
Here it is.
So I requested a horizontal
resolution of 80 cats.
So this might take 10 or 15
seconds, but spoiler alert,
it will work in the end.
Yeah, there she is.
And if I click to zoom, she's
made full of little cats.
This is great, and this
would make actually
a very good background picture.
But if I wanted to
print a poster to upload
to a poster-printing
company, I would
need a really high resolution.
So for this I would ask
for more cats, 120 cats.
This is not the total
number of cats, of course.
It's only on each line,
and of course for printing
I would need all the cats
to be at least, let's say,
128 pixel widths.
Let's generate.
Spoiler alert, it will
fail, but it was planned.
OK, let's let it fail.
And the error message
will look just the same.
I have exceeded the memory
of instance of 1 gigabyte.
So what do I do?
I deploy the same application
to Kubernetes Engine.
OK, let's open
that up, and I will
request 120 cats wide and
128 pixel wide for each cat.
With that, I should be
able to print a poster
at least 2 meters high.
That's my goal.
So it will take a while.
Meanwhile, I can show
you that it's really
a Kubernetes cluster.
So yes, I have a cluster, check.
I have a GKE service, check.
I have a GKE workload,
whatever that might be.
And I have the
deployment details
of the underlying
Compute Engine machines.
Where is that?
Maybe I'm not on
the right screen.
Yes, so VM instance is here, and
I can see that each of my nodes
have eight virtual CPUs
and 50 gigabytes of memory.
50 gigabytes, that should be
enough to produce Mona Lisa.
Yes, she is being generated.
That is so huge.
I will be able to send that
file to the printing company.
And if I want an even
higher resolution,
then I wouldn't
use a web browser
because displaying a
multigigapixel picture
in the browser, that
doesn't end up very well.
But I can use CURL for that
because the server and GKE will
handle the load
no problem, and I
will get my huge file with
many billions of pixels
and send that for printing.
OK, very cool.
Stackdriver Profiler,
so I'll open it,
and I'll explain in a
minute how to read that.
So with very little
extra configuration,
I can have a profiler agent
collect more information
about what is
going on in the CPU
and in the memory of
the compute instances.
So here I will filter
by today, one day,
and I will take the top
5% of what happened.
Wait, top 5%.
So this is a flame graph of the
mosaic computation, the "Mona
Lisa" with cats that we've seen.
And we'll see in a few
minutes how to read this,
but basically there
is a process function,
and inside the process function
my code is in another function,
colorizeCat.
And quite a lot of the time
is also spent encoding to PNG.
But that will be
in a few minutes.
So cold starts-- they are
a true performance concern
in serverless applications.
A cold start is a
request response
that is much higher than
usual because the server is
warming up.
This happens either because
the app has very low traffic
and the first server
instance has to start
or because the
traffic is increasing
and the autoscaler decides
to start an extra instance.
In my experience,
Go applications
tend to have fast cold starts
as they don't need a JVM
and also because, thanks
to the standard library,
they usually don't need to
load hundreds of megabytes
of library dependencies.
For example, my Go apps
deployed an App Engine
standard have cold starts
that are under 2 seconds.
And 2 seconds only, that's
a pretty good cold start.
The last word about serverless--
we've just announced
Cloud Run this week
which lets you deploy
your own containers
to our serverless platform, and
this is huge on so many levels.
More specifically
with Cloud Run on GKE,
you can achieve
vertical scalability
by choosing your custom machines
with more memory and more CPU
calls and still scale to
zero in a serverless way.
Now let's have a look
at the Go tooling.
The tools that I'm going to show
are not specific to the cloud.
They can run on your
development laptop,
and they run on VMs as well.
It's perfectly fine to do
some performance exploration
on your own computer,
but remember
that it's more
relevant to run them
in a production environment.
Also, the measurements
in production
sometimes dispel the workstation
measurements as well as
my best intuitions.
In Go, this is how you
run the automated tests.
All Go programmers are familiar
with this command line.
I encourage to explore
performance in test files
as the standard testing
package plays very nicely
with the performance tooling.
My demo today will use
go test, but remember
that the same tools
can be used for any Go
executable or server.
And this is how you
run your benchmarks,
integrated in the
go test command
with an additional flag.
This is a powerful performance
feature of the Go tooling
[INAUDIBLE] two benchmarks
calling functions A and B,
respectively, and see which
one of the two is the fastest.
So these are two functions A
and B. They do the same thing.
They are trying to determine
if the word database--
here it is--
is contained in
this article here.
So spoiler alert,
the answer is yes.
The word database is here.
And here are the unit tests.
They check that
it is true indeed,
and here are the two
benchmarks for A and B.
So let's run the tests.
Yeah, they work.
They pass.
More specifically, test
A and test B are passing.
This is good.
Now let's hang the benchmarks.
So this is telling us that
function A was executed
10 million times and took
on average 220 nanoseconds,
and function B was
executed 20 million times
and took on average
100 milliseconds, which
means that in this case,
string.contains is twice
as fast as a regular
expression, which
is good to know if
we want to decide
which one to put in production.
Trace-- this is an
execution tracer.
It works by instrument
being the program
to produce a binary
file containing
the activity of each CPU
core over a period of time.
Is the CPU idle?
Is it running the
garbage collector?
Is it running a function,
and what is the call trace?
This is a CPU-bound
sequential task.
You can see that only one
of the CPU cores is active,
and the other ones are idle.
It turns out that the same
sequential computation
may be dispatched
on several CPU cores
by the scheduler
of the Go runtime.
This doesn't involve
any concurrency.
Only one CPU core is
working at any given time.
Now this is an example
of concurrent computation
using several goroutines.
You can see that all
the calls are busy.
This can be good or
bad, but it doesn't mean
that the program is efficient.
Having a lot of goroutines
communicating and synchronizing
with each other can lead
to contention and to a lot
of expensive context switching.
That wasn't supposed
to happen like that.
Quite often, an inappropriate
granularity for the goroutines
can lead to worse performance
with four CPU cores
than the same sequential
task on one single CPU core.
The best multicore
performance is
achieved when each
goroutine performs
a fair amount of sequential
work before writing to a channel
or releasing a mutex or
decrementing a WaitGroup.
So I'm going to run
them as a benchmark
once again but this
time instrumented them
with the execution tracer and
outputting a binary file a.out.
By the way, these
are the benchmark
of the mosaic generation
with the cat and "Mona Lisa."
Great.
Now let's view the result--
go tool trace -http :6060--
that's for my window
on the right--
and the file a.out.
So what do we have here?
Quite a lot of information.
So at the top we
can see at any--
so each horizontal
axis is the time.
That's a few seconds.
That's the duration
of my benchmark
because my code is executed
over and over for a few seconds.
So we can see at any
given time how many
goroutines existed here.
We can see the heaps or how
much memory was actually
consumed in orange and
available to the Go runtime.
That's in green.
And we can see how many
operating system threads
are running at this instant.
And below for each
processor, so each CPU core,
we can see if it's busy
or idle, and we can see
what it is doing at that time.
So if I click anywhere here--
can we read?
Yes, we can read a little bit.
So it was, at that
time, encoding some PNG
using the standard library.
So if I go to another
slice, you can
see that only one
CPU core is active
because my core is sequential.
So here it's also
encoding some PNG.
Here it's decoding some JPEG.
Oh yes, the input "Mona
Lisa," that was JPEG.
And there are four
lines of processor
because I have four
CPU cores on my laptop.
Now Pprof.
Pprof is the profiling
data format available out
of the box in Go.
Let's have a look at
the Pprof CPU profiler.
The CPU profiling
works by sampling.
It includes a relatively
small runtime overhead.
Every now and then the kernel
sends a SIGPROF signal,
and the special handler
of the Go runtime
gather the call trace of one
currently running goroutine.
The data set of all these call
traces over a period of time
contains rich
statistical information
that is used to produce a
graph of the function showing
who calls who and how much
time is spent in each function.
In the resulting graph,
each box is a function
and explicitly
displays the number
of seconds spent inside the code
of the function, the total time
spent in the function, including
its own function calls,
and the equivalent percentage
of the total execution time
recorded.
Running the benchmarks
is a very effective way
to gather this information
as the functions are
called many times over
a short period of time.
At the top, you will find
the program's entry point
and your own
important functions.
And at the bottom are all the
standard library functions
and the system calls.
The duration of
each box consists
in the sum of its own
CPU time plus all the CPU
times of the function it calls.
This counts only the time
actually spent using the CPU,
not the time spent
waiting for something.
So once again I will
run the benchmarks,
this time instrumented with
the CPU profiler of Pprof
to a binary file a.prof.
And it's important to not
care at all about the results,
the number from the benchmarks.
These numbers are skewed
by instrumentation.
Here, I am only interested
into the visualization.
go tool pprof, OK.
-http :6060, that's for
my window on the right,
and the binary file a.prof.
So what can we see?
We can see that,
in my benchmark,
the process function,
which creates the mosaic
took 90% of the total time.
My own code, colorizeCat,
it took only 19%
of the total time.
And the PNG encoding, which is
a part of the standard library
and which happens only at
the end of the processing,
it accounts for 53%
of the total time.
This is highly valuable insight.
If I wanted to
optimize my own code,
I would only be able to optimize
less than 20% of the workload.
The bottleneck is the
standard library function
of PNG encoding,
which is not my code
and which I can't really
parallelize on multiple cores
because it is called
only once at the end
of the mosaic generation.
However, now that I know that
the encoding is the bottleneck,
I decide to not
buffer the output.
The only advantage of
buffering in my previous code
was to log the precise
number of bytes written.
That was the length
of the byte buffer.
If I give the response
writer directly
to the process
function, the browser
now receives the streamed
data as it is being encoded.
This is a good UX feedback
because the user sees
the first kitties displayed
much sooner than before,
and it also greatly improves
the total response time
because the encoding
is effectively
parallelized with the
response data being
downloaded by the client.
I'm missing a slide.
OK, no problem.
So as I mentioned
earlier, everyone
has intuitions about
expected performance.
There is also sometimes
some emotional investments
and some prejudice
on this topic.
I suggest to stick to
the facts and to discover
the current bottleneck.
What takes the most
time in my use case?
Everything that is not
the bottleneck can wait.
Now the flame graphs.
A flame graph is a fancy way to
visualize the profiling data.
It was invented by Brenden
Gregg and around 2013.
So I will run just the
same command as before,
go tool pprof with -http :6060.
I cannot just rerun the same.
I have to write it
all over, and a.prof.
So if I click in
View, Flame Graph,
I have this, which
is really nice.
It is not completely
of use the first time
we see a flame graph,
but the horizontal
axis x doesn't represent
the chronological time.
However, the widths
of each span is
proportional to
the total duration
spent executing this function.
So here I have two
benchmarks, benchmark process
and benchmark process in memory.
If I click on this
one, I can see
that my own code colorizeCat
is only part of the total.
Decoding the JPEG of
"Mona Lisa" is like 15%,
and the PNG encoding at the end
accounts for more than half.
So if I am curious and I want to
know what the standard library
is doing while
writing the image,
I can dig deeper and
deeper because it
is really great to find the
root cause of some latency.
Do we have at least
seven minutes?
Yes we do.
OK.
Why should I look
at a flame graph
if it basically displays
the same information
as the regular Pprof graph?
This is a
stereotypical workday--
work in the morning, work in the
afternoon, and sleep all night.
And this is a
stereotypical vacation day.
Sleep in the morning, go to
the beach in the afternoon,
and dance all night.
And this is what the
Pprof graph looks
like if you run a
simulation containing
some people in activity and
some people in vacation.
Some functions--
for example, sleep--
are called by everyone but not
at the same time of the day.
Even with a complete set
of duration annotations,
this graph doesn't
give enough information
to know if going to the
beach, the yellow box,
is part of work day or a part
of vacation days or both.
Maybe some employees
prefer to skip work.
This flame graph built out of
the same profiling information
quickly gives the answer.
The beach activity on the
right is properly stacked only
under the vacation-day box.
And we also discover that a
vacation day typically involves
a bit more sleep than a workday.
So the bottom line
is flame graphs
are very beautiful
like a campfire
and also super useful
to find the root
cause of latency issues.
If you suspect that the
performance of your program
is not correctly explained
by trace and Pprof,
you may want to use
the perf tool, which
is not specific to Go.
Now concurrency--
concurrency and parallelism
are powerful tools to do
several things at once
and help decrease the total
latency of your request.
As we've seen, a lot of the
time spent in a web service
is spent waiting for
an API call to return.
In this case, the performance
is not related at all
to the number of
CPU cores and not
related to the speed
of each CPU core.
It is, however,
extremely useful to be
able to call several
external APIs concurrently.
I have to be quick on this one.
This command, it runs a test.
Who has ever run the
data race detector?
OK, you already know about it.
It's super useful
to stay on track
because when you work on
performance optimization,
sometimes you introduce
concurrencies and channels
and goroutines, and you
introduce subtle bugs,
and it is really useful
to detect those bugs
as soon as possible.
There is no such thing as
a harmless data race in Go.
We have to be careful.
Here is a quick checklist of
common performance bottlenecks
and how we can
advise them in Go.
The ever-popular execution
of useless instructions--
obviously hunting and
eliminating useless code
is a good idea.
Please do it.
Now network, IU, and
external API calls
are relatively
extremely expensive.
My advice is to make as
few requests as possible
and not to block everything
while waiting for a network
response.
Reading from and writing
to the file system
is slower than most of what we
do in memory and in the CPU.
So my advice is to work as
much as you can in memory
and to do your I/O
in a nonblocking way.
I know some are taking pictures,
but I am running out of time.
Contention-- thousands
of goroutines
waiting for each other
is a perfect recipe
for unnecessary sluggishness.
To limit the excessive need
for constant communication
between goroutines, I
suggest to create workers.
The worker pattern,
it look like this.
If I have four CPU cores
and 1 million computations
to perform, yes, I could
launch 1 million goroutines,
but that would be a little
bit heavy and costly.
It's more efficient to start
a small number of worker
goroutinees, say eight, and have
each worker process only 1/8
of the total load sequentially.
Asking for memory to
the operating system
is a notoriously slow operation.
My advice is to allocate
large chunks of memory
in a single call to the
built-in make function,
to use memory by passing
both buffers as arguments
to the processing functions, and
also using a pool from the sync
package can prove very useful.
Heap or stack-- this part is
specific to the Go compiler.
We know that allocating
in the heap is expensive
and that allocating on
the stack is almost free,
but what goes in the heap
and what goes to the stack?
The answer is not intuitive.
Some local variable
may escape to the heap
if we take its reference
and pass it along.
In the end, it depends if
the compiler is clever enough
to prove that a variable
doesn't escape so it
is safe to put it on the stack.
These commands
prove scientifically
that the core
specification does not
contain the word stack or heap.
Use this extra gcflag,
-m, to determine which
local variables escape or not.
You may then try to
adapt the function
scope to leak less references.
Regular expressions are
great, but they are often
overkill for a given need.
So my advice is basically
to avoid them when you can.
Just two seconds
on the next slide.
Function calls-- a function
call incur nonzero cost, which
can be significant if the
function is very small
and they're called
millions of times.
So the specification does not
talk at all about inlining,
and the compiler has its own
very specific internal rules
when it comes to decide if a
small function will be inline
or not.
Chasing the inliner to have it
inline a specific hot function
has become a popular sport.
Also, these
implementation details
are subject to change from
a Go release to another.
Before I finish, I'd like
to thank my colleague, David
Gageot, for his wonderful
presentation tool
DemoIt, which I am using today.
And also why do I have
two remote clickers?
Because I'm worth it.
Here is my takeaway.
The Go language was
designed for cloud computing
with scalability in mind.
Its ecosystem is rich, and
the performance tooling
is really good.
Now to improve the experience
of your users and make the world
a better place.
Start with an
important use case.
Discover the bottleneck.
Fix it, and repeat.
Thank you very
much for listening.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]